voilà par là ni moi pour en retard
bonjour à tous alors pour un c je sais
pas si c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise
nouvelle mais en tout cas si la dernière
convention sous cette forme que nous
tenons nous en avons tenu je parle sous
le contrôle de deux francs cuisine
georges je crois une 16 ou 17
nous avons tenu aussi des rendez vous du
projet qui à côté des conventions
permettait d' approfondir tel ou tel
sujet il y en a eu plusieurs
plusieurs dizaines et nous terminons ce
travail par une revue de ce que nous
pourrions être amenés à proposer pour
modifier allégé rendre plus souple plus
agile nos institutions ne parle pas de
6ème république
évidemment la vème république a fait la
preuve de sa solidité et également de
l'efficacité de son organisation
on voit bien qu'il ya beaucoup de points
à changer si on veut que la république
continue à incarner quelque chose de
très très important c'est à dire le lien
de confiance entre elles mêmes entre
ceux qui décident au nom des du peuple
et puis le peuple lui même ce que ce qui
s'est passé ce week end à londres le
rappelle évidemment de façon très très
cruel donc nous devons faire évoluer nos
institutions et c'est le thème de cette
de cette journée alors cette journée
va commencer par une table ronde qui
sera présidée par guillaume larrivé et
qui présentera sa table ronde
et puis la deuxième table ronde sera
présidée par daniel fasquelle
l'idée elle est d'un côté de regarder on
l'organisation elle même des
institutions les points sur lequel très
précis vous verrez on peut être amené à
demander des modifications
on n'est pas dans les grandes idées on
est dans réellement aussi le pragmatisme
total
nous devons avoir des institutions
efficaces si on veut mettre en musique
en oeuvre une réforme efficace nécessité
d'avoir des institutions qui tiennent le
choc la nécessité de réformer passe par
des institutions qu'ils soient capables
de d'absorber les décisions qui sont
prises
et puis après de faciliter leur mise en
oeuvre si les institutions blog très
beau vouloir réformer n'y aura pas de
réformes qui qui voulons c'est donc une
condition nécessaire du redressement de
notre pays
et puis daniel fasquelle présidera sa
table ronde sur un sujet très important
qui est au fond l'organisation de la
république les collectivités locales
territoriales le rôle des unes et des
autres on voit bien que c'est un sujet
qui est sans arrêt revient à l'ordre du
jour parfois d'ailleurs au grand dam des
des élus qui trouvent que mais si sans
arrêt en train d'être modifiée
nous devrons là aussi apporter des
propositions très précises
françois baroin d'ailleurs nous nous
rejoindra et puis nous parlerons de
numérique avant d'essayer de rapprocher
les français en tout cas les électeurs
les citoyens delà des décisions qui sont
prises ya le référendum qui a beaucoup
d'autres sujets et donc on parlera aussi
de cette république numérique qui
pourrait de plus en plus poindre son nez
et faire en sorte que nos citoyens
soient de plus en plus écoutée et en
tout cas entendue en tout cas merci à
vous d'être fidèle à ces conventions
elles seront évidemment terminée conclut
par nicolas sarkozy aux alentours de
2010 et puis le 2 juillet c'est à dire
maintenant dans quelques jours le 2
juillet un conseil national des
républicains entérinera je l'espère
votera le projet d république a composé
toutes ces conventions qui ont été
votées par les militants
et puis bien évidemment un texte de
synthèse qui résumera un peu tout cela
mais ça c'est le sujet du samedi 2
juillet voilà a tout de suite